هذا وقالت السلطات الاوكرانيه ان مسيرات
روسيه استهدفت احد الموانئ جنوب غربي
اوديسا وقد اظهرت صور تم تداولها عمليات
الحرائق التي اندلعت على اثر الهجوم اضافه
الى اثر الدمار الذي لحق بالمنشاه في
الميناء وقد اكد سره براتشوك المتحدث باسم
الاداره العسكريه في مدينه اوديستا
الاوكرانيه وقوعه اضرار بالميناء وصوامع
الحبوب فيها
يستمر العدو بتكتيكاته لتدمير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه هذا ما يستهدفه العدو من هجومه
على منشاه الموانئ وهذا ما استهدفه العدو
في جنوب اوديسا حيث نفذت غاره بالطائرات
المسيره وللاسف هناك اصابه لموقع وتضررت
الصوامع جميع فرق الطوارئ في الموقع روسيا
دوله ارهابيه ولن نمكنها من تنفيذ خطتها
في الاثناء قال رئيس الاوكراني ان الهجمات
الروسيه على الموانئ وصانع الحبوب في
اوديسا تستهدف الامن الغذائي العالمي واكد
في بياننا الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
دمرت عددا من المسيرات التي استهدفت عده
مناطق في اوكرانيا ليله امس وقال زيلنسكي
انه يجب على العالم ان يستجيب عندما يتم
استهداف الموانئ المدنيه وعندما يقوم
وصفهم بالارهابيين بتدمير صوامع الحبوب
عمدا وفقا تعبيره
من جانبه قال المتحدث باسم قوات الغرب في
الجيش الروسي
سركينا قوته تمكنت من السيطره على مواقع
للقوات الاوكرانيه وذلك باتجاه واوضحت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انظمه الدفاع الجوي
احبطت محاوله استهداف مناطق حيويه في وسط
موسكو بواسطه مسيرات وهذا الهجوم هو
الثالث الذي يستهدف العاصمه خلال اسبوع